okay so so that's 30 months this is 30.
it's about three years then
yeah all together so you did two years
in coleman got out and then you did
you started carting again yeah i started
[ __ ] around again
right as soon as i got ahead and this
was after matt met you wrote the
synopsis and he was trying to call you
yeah yeah yeah
i got i started [ __ ] around again and
you got six months
no you talking on the phone you just
disappeared talk on the phone
he's like yeah yeah just one day phone
dude this is how
this [ __ ] dude i got [ __ ] i got so i
ordered so i go back through my my
connect right i
call my dude from china and i got
holograms coming in
right after i after this is after i'm in
i'm living in miami i just got the
halfway house i'm in a [ __ ] studio
bedroom
i'm in a studio apartment and then
[ __ ] and i was in like i was living
in like a
little havana or something like that in
miami what happened to the bank account
with all the money and it was completely
depleted
it's gone i don't have access to it
yeah i don't have access to that what
happened to it
uh my debit cards and and all that [ __ ]
got thrown out
my wife because we were getting pulled
over like so when i got picked up in
temple terrace
yeah um
i thought for sure they're gonna come to
the house and search
right when i got picked up right you
know what i mean i was unaware that i
had a warrant
from the other [ __ ] from you know years
prior or whatever
right and that's what it was for so when
i told my wife i was like listen as soon
as you get home
get rid of everything whatever i have
there just get rid of it
you know what i mean dispose of it okay
and because i thought they were going to
come and search and if they would have
found all that [ __ ] out i would
[ __ ] i'd still be in prison you know
they would have
they would have built a prison and named
it after me so
and um so yeah she went home and she got
rid of everything she [ __ ] just
destroyed everything threw it away i
don't know what the [ __ ] she did with it
and so i go to jail and i was in jail
for a little while and then i come home
and i was like you know she's like i got
rid of everything
good like where are the debit cards did
they ever come to search for it no
no they never came never came to my
house to search because the warrant
wasn't for that i wasn't getting picked
up for that like i thought i was
i thought i was getting picked up for
that for specifically what i was doing
at the moment but it was for what i had
already done
and um so yeah it's the the
to clarify the warrant that he was being
picked up on was for
the south carolina arrest which they've
already confiscated all of
their stuff right he's thinking it's for
a second
indictment out of out of um
uh nevada so he's thinking they're gonna
come to the house
again equipment but they don't you
already had bought a
shitload of more equipment i had all new
equipment you had all kinds of i
read up i read up and went for a [ __ ]
second run yeah
okay so you i was trying to i was trying
to do the big dirty you call your wife
all the cards and she would do all the
equipment she tossed it
threw it away so you came home after
going to jail for how long
i was going for i was only going like a
week or something like that a week or
two
so i had to go to court and then all
right so all your money is on all these
different
spread out and all these different debit
cards how much money was it
i want to say the i know the boa for
sure had over a million dollars in it at
the time
and then i maybe had a maybe 120 000
spread out throughout the throughout the
western union cards
because i i mean i had close to three
and a half million dollars at the
beginning
but i went on just a rampage like a two
like a two year rampage
almost and then i met my wife in miami
and then i calmed down and
i tried it's like okay i'm just gonna go
straight now so all of those cards the
million
one point whatever million just gone
poof
it up and vanished like a [ __ ] fart
in the wind and there was nothing i
could do about it
and i believe me i'm still sick to my
stomach to this day what
was your reaction when you found out she
threw everything snapped out but it was
just like
my initial reaction was i snapped out
and then
we sat down and we had a conversation
about it and it was like
i i tried to go and look where she said
she threw the stuff away at and
the garbage the garbage had been taken
out you know what i mean like
i i was thinking about going to the
[ __ ] landfill and digging through
[ __ ] like i just didn't like i didn't
know like i didn't you know i mean like
all these ideas are running through my
head like this can't be it
like this just can't be it it can't this
can't be this can't be the end of it
this can't be the end this can't be it
and it was just it was over
it's [ __ ] all over yeah it's all over
going to the landfill that's extreme
yeah you're there people have done much
worse for [ __ ]
less money for half that amount you know
what i mean so
i'll i'll go [ __ ] dig through [ __ ]
piss and [ __ ] you know what i mean to
get those goddamn debit cards back but
they were just gone everything was gone
and it was over the ride was over i had
literally no money
like nothing i had maybe 10 000 in cash
in a [ __ ] shoe box somewhere and that
was it
and i was going to prison and i was out
on [ __ ] uh um um yeah
supervised release here's the and they
let him out on bond again
that's what i understand i can't get
[ __ ] bond they let him out
they grab him they keep letting him out
they let him out again
and then he doesn't report he stops he
goes he goes to [ __ ]
um michigan went to michigan
yeah came back and then eventually they
catch up with them how many how
long after they caught up with you what
do you do after you find after you
[ __ ]
have this coming to jesus moment where
you realize
all of your millions of dollars are gone
and you have nothing it was all downhill
after that
these are the bad times is that when you
started [ __ ] what happened yeah
now what happens dude i'm broke i got
[ __ ] i'm i'm married i got a kid
that's not like nine months old
i go to prison i'm broke i go to prison
and it was i [ __ ] i lost everything
did everything everything i had all my
cars
everything i had like my i don't know
all my sneakers [ __ ] i'm like
in prison i'm like okay at least i'm
gonna get out and have some gear
you know what i mean at least i'm
[ __ ] get out and having [ __ ] a
little something you know i mean some
clothes some shoes you know what i'm
saying so the [ __ ]
the fruits all the [ __ ] that i had
[ __ ] got with all you know me at
least i'll have that when i get out
all [ __ ] gone yep
god wife got knocked up by some other
dude no
swear to god oh i didn't know that yeah
i get out i'm in the halfway house were
you still talking to your wife when you
were in prison
i remember i remember when she didn't
really write me that much she never came
i didn't i didn't get one visit the
whole time i was there the whole two
years
um she wrote me like once or twice
no you were getting email you she was
emailing you yeah yeah but
those got cut off after a minute oh okay
and so i was like whatever
you know what did you worry about it
when you were in there no i wasn't
because she
every time i talked to her she's like
baby everything's fine i love you
so to give her a little bit of credit
thank you for that
you know me that kept you kind thank you
for not [ __ ] on me like listen i'm
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] this dude right now
and you know what i mean like yeah at
least you know what i mean don't [ __ ]
tell me that [ __ ] you know i mean at
least [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i mean i could see
that my time was a little bit easier
i mean i didn't really have that much
time yeah whatever and uh yeah i get out
i'm in the halfway house she's got some
dude living with her at her [ __ ] mom
and dad's
right i'm [ __ ] her as soon as i get
out of the halfway house
the day i get out i'm [ __ ] her and
she's going back to this dude she's got
living with
that's my wife dude we're [ __ ]
married we have a kid together what are
you doing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you know what are you doing yeah so
she's still with this dude and i'm still
[ __ ] her you know what i mean like
so yeah so she she dips out like one day
she just disappears
and she goes to [ __ ] nebraska
she disappears to nebraska and i'm on
i'm on i'm on
i'm on federal probation at this time
because i just got out of halfway house
i'm on federal probation
and she she just disappears i'm like
okay whatever
i'm in miami i'm [ __ ] i'm working at
this warehouse in miami
and it's grueling man i mean i'm having
to wake up at three o'clock in the
morning
and i was living in uh i was living down
like 12th and flagler
in little havana which is like right by
like miami high school which is kind of
like by downtown but not really like you
got to go down flagler waves before you
get downtown miami
and so i had to walk every morning
because i didn't have a car sending [ __ ]
when i got it halfway house and i had
nothing
no money i came home to nothing no no
nothing dude i had like [ __ ] one pair
of shoes that i got bought while i was
in prison
from prison commissary [ __ ] nikes you
know [ __ ] this is you buy nikes and
prison commissions oh yeah yeah yeah
what oh yeah oh yeah i didn't know that
i mean they're not nice
not like [ __ ] retro jordans or
anything i mean they're like socks and
t-shirts and [ __ ] from [ __ ] prison
i still wear i [ __ ] got rid of all
that [ __ ] i can still wear it you battle
lebron's in prison
nah they they're not they're not cool
nikes you know what i mean it's not
they're not the good ones you know what
i'm saying but they're nikes
so yeah so i'm rocking prison nikes you
know what i mean i'm getting up at three
o'clock in the morning and i'm [ __ ] i
gotta walk
all the way downtown miami from 12th and
flagler and
that's a rough part of town in miami
that's a [ __ ] pretty rough part of
miami
and at three o'clock in the morning
there's no buses running so i gotta walk
all the way downtown at three in the
morning because i gotta catch the very
first train that leaves downtown miami
that goes all the way to [ __ ] uh
hialeah which is an hour train ride but
i gotta catch the first one because i
gotta be to work at a certain time in
the morning
so i gotta catch the first train to go
an hour to catch a bus to ride a bus an
hour to go to work
to work [ __ ] in a warehouse for 10 12
hours a day and then have to run that
whole [ __ ]
back again all the way to the house i
was doing that as soon as i got out of
prison
you know what i mean i'm used to driving
brand new [ __ ] cars and doing
whatever the [ __ ] i want to do
and now i'm i'm i'm a [ __ ] cockroach
down here in miami doing nothing
so it was like i only could i could only
take a couple months of that and i was
just like i was at my breaking point to
where i was like listen
i'm going to kill myself like this is
i'm there's because for me let me look
at me i'm [ __ ] tattooed
i mean i have an education i have my
associate's degree you know what i mean
and i kind of feel like i can articulate
my myself well and i have a vocabulary
and i speak well but
that people don't see that and people
don't give a [ __ ] about your associate's
degree
when you bend the prison and you look
the way i do they just don't care right
so any kind of situation that i go into
that's a regular kind of employment
situation
i'm not making it [ __ ] very high on
the corporate ladder no you know made
that decision a long time ago yeah that
that's
it is what it is and i'm fine with that
but
here i am i have to have a job because
i'm on probation
you know what i mean my federal [ __ ]
probation and i got this probation
officer which she was really [ __ ]
cool she she
didn't really give a [ __ ] what i did but
um
i could only do it for two months and i
was just over it and i was just i was
just like i can't do this anymore i'm
[ __ ] over it
and i was [ __ ] this girl from the
halfway house that i met in the halfway
house
and like her brother like i started
[ __ ] with her brother
and her brother kind of was like wanted
to like he kind of knew
about like i kind of told him like what
i had done like my past and
kind of knew about like everything and
he was like he kind of wanted to jump
into
it and he kind of put up the money
he didn't kind of he did put up the
money he put up the money and we bought
bought the equipment
and i [ __ ] suited up for another run
dude the third one i'm like you know
what this is going to be the big dirty
the last hurrah i'm getting i'm gonna
i'm gonna get a million
and i'm gonna go ahead and invest it and
and you know what i mean open like a
legitimate business and pay taxes and
all that [ __ ]
didn't go that way uh she turned out to
be a complete [ __ ] psychopath
oh wait is this the chick the statue
yeah oh
yeah listen this story like there's a
whole other series of stuff
like he got this chick stabbed me with a
pair of scissors
and almost almost killed me where'd she
stab you
in my chest bounced off my breastplate
yeah almost almost killed me and then um
so yeah that went that whole thing went
pretty south pretty fast and then
so then i'm [ __ ] with this chick and
her brother wants to you know get into
it
and he bought the equipment so yeah so i
i ordered my i contact my my
my dude in china and i get some some
holograms sent in
and they get they get they get stopped
at customs because i'm tracking my
package
and i can see it says customs hold on it
so i'm like [ __ ]
they got it which it's fine because i'm
like it's not in my name it's not coming
to my apartment right right right
i get about a week two weeks later i'm i
i get two
dhl the delivery service dhl uh dudes at
my door knocking
and i look at my people when i see two
dhl dudes i'm like what the [ __ ] so i
open the door
two and he's got this he's got this
yellow he's got this envelope and his
hand is wrapped in yellow tape
and that's anything that comes from
china i don't know if you've ever
ordered anything from china
but they use this this industry
you can see it from a mile if you see it
you know what it is like anything that
comes from china like if you order bulk
anything from china they wrap it in this
like this
yellow [ __ ] tape you know what i mean
so i seen the packaging
in his hand i knew exactly what it was
immediately because i had ordered
holograms from this dude before
so right then and there i'm like [ __ ]
and he's like uh
he's like they were like and i didn't
have my name on it obviously he's like
uh
he he's like this is the package is for
you and he showed me like no they don't
live here
and he's like he's like you sure he's
like how long have you been living here
i was like i just moved in like
that's already too many questions about
a month ago i was like yeah i was like
uh yeah
are you sure dhl he's like he's so he's
like okay and so i closed the door
and and he walked away and i immediately
i was like [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
[ __ ] that [ __ ] me i'm done i'm going
back to prison come on listen i just got
out of prison i just got a [ __ ]
federal halfway house i'm on federal
probation you know what i mean it's all
bad
it's just all bad yeah and um
so he comes back to the door i haven't
heard this i've like i heard
i knew you got a story no i knew you i
knew we got arrested like we were on the
phone when he said [ __ ] they showed up
at my [ __ ] house they grabbed me they
rest they no they brought arrested they
brought you downtown i knew that
but i haven't heard this whole thing
yeah and
um so yeah so then i hear bam bam bam
bam bam at the door i'm like [ __ ] he's
like police
and then now they're yelling police so
i'm like [ __ ] dude
i'm looking at the side window you know
what i'm saying i'm thinking about
jumping out the [ __ ] side window and
then dipping them like wait a minute
i'm thinking in my head i was like i
don't have anything here i was like they
don't [ __ ] have anything on me i was
like all they have is this package that
came to my door
and you've already denied it so i opened
the door back up i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] ride this thing all the way out
[ __ ] these [ __ ] yeah you know
what i mean who the [ __ ] do they think
they are
coming here trying to arrest me you know
what i mean i'm gonna [ __ ] talk my
way out of this [ __ ] like i do
everything
else i'm talking my way out of it right
and i'm still i got them convinced at
this point like i got them convinced at
this point that it might not be me
like they think it's me but they might
not it might not be me and i haven't
but they don't know but they don't
because they don't have i'm not
registered to this address
oh and you haven't they don't have your
name they haven't given i haven't given
them my driver's license or anything yet
right
okay i didn't know so i'm we're we're
talking we're in my kitchen
fedex shows up what a giant [ __ ] box
of what a [ __ ] embossing machine
somebody else ordered an
embossing machine to your address that's
crazy who would do that
while they're in there talking to you
yeah well while the [ __ ]
i almost had him i almost [ __ ] had
him until this the [ __ ] fedex [ __ ]
shows up with this giant box
i didn't know that's good and when the
box shows up it shows up to the same
name
as the [ __ ] as the holograms were
showing up for
and the police went out there and talked
to him to your advantage though no it
didn't because they went out here and
talked to him
and he's like he's like yeah i've
delivered several packages to this
address and he's he signed for him
right there they [ __ ] had me no right
there they [ __ ] had me
yeah they knew i couldn't talk my way
out of it then they knew and i had to
give them my id and they ran they found
out what i'd just been to prison for
and they're like okay all right so at
this point i'm like oh i'm [ __ ]
this is it it's all over with i'm going
back to [ __ ] prison
all right i just got out i'm [ __ ]
going back
so he's like um we want the lab they
kept saying we want the lab we want the
lab
the lab yeah the the print shop because
i guess they had just busted
some people because miami is huge for
[ __ ] for fraud yeah miami is like
[ __ ] fraud central in the united
states it's
[ __ ] new york miami las vegas and and
los angeles are like
the crime hubs for for credit card fraud
and for identity theft and all that [ __ ]
so